all right daniel jones quarterback of
the new york giants we talked about him
earlier this is year three an important
year for him co-owner john mara recently
meeting with the media addressed
the way the team feels about their
former top 10 pick
we think the world of daniel in this
building i think i've said that publicly
before i know our coaches feel very
strong about him we want to see him take
the next step i don't have any specific
benchmarks other than you know let's win
some more games
i think
he will have a better team around him
this year than he has had in previous
years so we certainly expect him to take
the next step but
i'm not going to put any specific
benchmarks on him right now i just want
to i want to see him continue to improve
because i think he does have what it
takes
to be a long-term winner in this league
like any other owner you're completely
and totally behind your employee who has
promise and potential until you're not
it all depends i believe on what happens
this year shireen i'm not a big fan on
the idea that dave gettleman's on the
hot seat joe judge is only in year two
the giants need to be a little more
patient i think that's been one of the
problems john mara gets impatient every
few years and it freaks out his
employees and they tighten up just let
you got four super bowl trophies go
shine them go look at them go admire
them there's still plenty of teams that
don't have one you got to give things
some time and they got to give daniel
jones some time but in today's nfl time
runs out eventually on whether or not
your quarterback can play and i think
we're going to learn a lot about daniel
jones this year yeah you know mike when
these guys used to be drafted high in
the first round they were there for a
long time right you look at sam bradford
because they had those huge contracts
and then we got the rookie wage scale
and everything changed so these guys now
are getting two and three years and
that's it you look at the dwayne haskins
and those types of guys
and they've moved on quickly after
they've been a first round pick the
teams just said hey we've got to get
better at this position so i think this
is a key year
for daniel jones to prove he is the guy
you know i talked about the other day on
on pft p.m his record as a starter in
college and the pros combined is 25 and
37. he hasn't proved it yet he hasn't
proved that he can go out and win games
as a starter 8 and 18
with the giants and he just has too many
turnovers that's been the thing for him
but i do agree with john mara he does
have a better team around him this year
they've done a lot of things in free
agency they guaranteed 120 million
dollars he has kenny galladay and he has
some other weapons with kyle rudolph so
he's not going to have any excuses he's
out of that now so go out and get it
done key year for him this year mike
the twitter handle is at nfl shereen for
those of you out there who would like to
quibble with her suggestion that
quarterback wins are indeed a stat
although we both agree that at some
level a good quarterback does help a
team win football games even though wins
and losses in and of themselves don't
reflect on an overall quarterback's
ability the great the great ones like
tom right that's that's the thing you
look at what tom brady did last year and
you can't tell me that a great
quarterback doesn't count for something
when it comes to winning football games
especially the biggest games of the year
but the giants have been to the playoffs
only one time since they won the biggest
game of the year 10 years ago in
indianapolis over the new england
patriots and they really do have a lot
of work to do and i almost sense that
there's desperation in the spending that
happened this year in free agency
desperation born of that that anxiety
created by an impatient owner in john
mara the money they spent it didn't feel
nearly as strategic shireen as what the
patriots did it reminds me very much and
i've said this a couple of times
recently of jerry reese the year that he
was on the hot seat before he eventually
got fired when he went out and he signed
janoris jenkins olivia vernon snacks
harrison money money money money money
to make the defense better i feel like
this year it was just money anywhere and
everywhere to address some of these
weaknesses that they they can't address
them all in the draft let's go out and
spend even if we're spending more than
we should let's just go spend because
we've got to make the team better
because if we don't people are going to
be fired
yeah and they feel like they've done
that and the jury's still out on whether
they have or not at this point mike but
you know if i was go and i don't know
why because you look at washington and i
think they're better than than what they
were and i think the cowboys as we
pointed out have the best quarterback in
the division but if i today was going to
pick a team i thought was going to win
the division i think i would pick the
giants and i don't know why again it's
just a feeling i have maybe it's joe
judge i just i really like what he did
in this first season i i just i think
the players he's different than other
bill belichick assistants i i just feel
like after one year that have come into
this league and i just think he did a
really good job and maybe that's where i
put my confidence in this team
but today if i had to pick a favorite
for the division i would pick the giants
wow wow let's write that down april 2nd
and it's not april 1 so she really means
it thank god april fool's day is is over
by the way folks let me peel back the
curtain a little bit shireen was very
stressed out that i was going to have
some sort of reaction to my second covid
vaccination shot that i received
yesterday
and i really considered not for very
long but i did seriously consider for a
short period of time
the possibility of texting her between
the six and seven a.m eastern time hour
five and six a.m central for her that i
really wasn't feeling well and she was
just gonna have to do it by herself
today because i know
that
you what you you have been having panic
attacks all week over the possibility
that i wasn't going to show up today
i knew when your second shot was mike it
was thursday and i kept saying you
better not be sick on friday i just knew
it was gonna happen but glad you're
feeling well and glad you're here or at
least faking it maybe it's just fake
feeling well
don't jinx it yet we still have 90
minutes to go and sorry eagles fans we
addressed the quarterbacks in
the other three teams in your division
but we've said all we can say about the
eagles quarterbacks and uh you get to a
point if you're an eagles fan where you
don't want to hear anymore
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports